(audience clapping)
- Martha made history
with her Sports Illustrated
swimsuit issue cover
at 81 years old.
(audience cheering)
First of all, ma'am.
- [Guest] Goodness.
- Every 81 year old out there is like,
this is not like the others.
Like this is like, it's in incre...
Why now?
Like, this is incredible.
- I wonder.
They never asked me before.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I would've done it when I was 40.
I looked great at 40.
(Kelly chuckling)
- Well, they think you
look great at 81 too.
So it's just I love that you did it too.
I think it was the most
popular one, right?
- [Martha] Yeah.
- Of the covers.
- Yeah, we got like many,
many billions of impressions.
- It was crazy.
I do think though, you aged really well,
so I don't know if that's
comparable to the rest of us,
but I don't know.
Did your mother influence you?
Didn't she kind of influence
your attitude about aging?
- Mom was great, and mom was beautiful,
and with it, and totally
alert and intelligent,
and she raised six kids.
- No.
- And she was great until the
day she passed away at 93, so.
- [Kelly] 93.
- And she's never sick,
and she was fantastic.
She was swimming every day, you know,
she's an amazing woman.
- What a great role model as well.
- Very, very good role model.
- Well, you were following in
those footsteps, aren't ya,
I was like, wow.